what is hydraulic fracturing or fracking
since the Industrial Revolution our
energy consumption has risen unceasingly
the majority of this energy consumption
is supplied by fossil fuels like coal or
natural gas recently there's been a lot
of talk about a controversial method of
extracting natural gas hydraulic
fracturing or fracking put simply
fracking describes the recovery of
natural gas from deep layers inside the
earth in this method porous rock is
fractured by the use of water sand and
chemicals in order to release the
enclosed natural gas the technique of
fracking has been known since the 1940s
nonetheless only in the last 10 years
has there been quite a fracking boom
especially in the USA this is because
most conventional natural gas sources in
America and on the European continent
have been exhausted thus prices for
natural gas and other fuels are rising
steadily significantly more complicated
and expensive methods like fracking have
now become attractive and profitable in
the meantime fracking has already been
used more than a million times in the
USA alone over 60% of all new oil and
gas wells are drilled by using fracking
now let's take a look at how fracking
actually works first a shaft is drilled
several hundred meters into the earth
from there a horizontal hole is drilled
into the gas bearing layer of rock next
the fracking fluid is pumped into the
ground using high-performance pumps
on average the fluid consists of eight
million litres of water which amounts to
about the daily consumption of 65,000
people plus several thousand tons of
sand and about two hundred thousand
liters of chemicals the mixture
penetrates into the rock layer and
produces innumerable tiny cracks the
sand prevents the cracks from closing
again the chemicals perform various
tasks among other things they compress
the water kill off bacteria or dissolve
minerals next the majority of the
fracking fluid is pumped out again and
now the natural gas can be recovered as
soon as the gas source is exhausted the
drill hole is sealed as a rule the
fracking fluid is pumped back into deep
underground layers and sealed in there
however fracking is also associated with
several considerable risks the primary
risk consists in the contamination of
drinking water sources fracking not only
consumes large quantities of fresh water
but in addition the water is
subsequently contaminated and is highly
toxic the contamination is so severe
that the water cannot even be cleaned in
a treatment plant even though the danger
is known and theoretically could be
managed in the USA already sources have
been contaminated due to negligence no
one yet knows how the enclosed water
will behave in the future since there
have not yet been any long-term Studies
on the subject the chemicals used in
fracking vary from the hazardous to the
extremely toxic and carcinogenic such as
benzyl or formic acid the companies
using fracking say nothing about the
precise composition of the chemical
mixture
but it is known that there are about 700
different chemical agents which can be
used in the process another risk is the
release of greenhouse gases the natural
gas recovered by fracking consists
largely of methane a greenhouse gas
which is 25 times more potent than
carbon dioxide
natural gas is less harmful than coal
when burned but nonetheless the negative
effects of fracking on the climate
balance are overall greater firstly the
fracking process requires a very large
consumption of energy secondly the drill
holes are quickly exhausted and it's
necessary to drill fracking holes much
more frequently than for classical
natural gas wells in addition about 3%
of the recovered gas is lost in the
extraction and escapes into the
atmosphere so how is fracking and its
expected benefits to be assessed when
the advantages are balanced against the
disadvantages when properly employed
this technique offers one way in the
short to medium term to meet our demand
for lower cost energy but the long term
consequences of fracking are unforeseen
and the risk to our drinking water thus
should not be underestimated
you